President Trump in North Korean leader  Kim jong-un will use a luxury resort for  their summit in singapore next week the  White House says they'll meet at the  capela hotel on sentosa island an area  known for its beaches golf courses and  an amusement park right the State  Department's former Special  Representative for North Korea that's Jo  Yoon told the Senate committee that mr.  Trump shouldn't place a bar too low on  denuclearization Yoon is doubtful that  North Korea will do that old signs are  in history they have not shown any signs  that they want to denuclearize but  however it is hypothesis worth testing  that we push to the limit weather so  that we can determine how serious it is  Yoon says that he worries that have  failed some it could lead to military  action